Sheldon yes I'm gonna miss you of course
you are this Thursday night after twelve
seasons and 279 episodes the Big Bang
Theory TVs number one comedy will end
its long run on CBS with a one-hour
series finale shears it's a milestone
show it's one of those shows that you
know you always when it's off you keep
thinking will we ever see it's like
again but I think more significantly was
it was a big hit at a time when you
don't see as many big hits on TV as you
used to but last year the seven-member
cast decided to call it quits while they
were still on top committing to one
final season in the past and even today
TV series often end their runs with
abrupt cancellations and little or no
fanfare but long-running shows sometimes
get the chance to reward loyal fans with
memorable final vows like the Mary Tyler
Moore Show I think we all need some
Kleenex friends seems smaller somehow
has it always been purple and of course
there was the two-hour finale of mash it
set a record that stands to this day
with more than 120 million viewers
the most-watched TV episode of all time
the series finale has to leave you
somewhat satisfied and it's what's hard
when the show is a successful is Big
Bang or other major finales over time is
that the expectations are so high it's
almost impossible to satisfy everybody
but not all final episodes end up being
celebrated some of left viewers well
lost while others have somehow managed
to disappoint even loyal fans will be
out in a year and then we'll be back
could be fun and one just left viewers
still some endings have become legendary
the Newhart finale the second Newhart
show finale was I think it's almost
always on everybody's top of the list
because the surprise was so great and it
was a reward to viewers who loved Bob
Newhart loved both of the shows but
always had a hankering for Suzanne
Pleshette for the original Bob and Emily
to wake up in bed and say the whole
thing was a dream
now viewers will just have to wait and
see if TVs current favorite comedy goes
out with a big bang it's such a pregnant
moment that last you just want it to tie
up in a really nice way I know I know
you know I never really got into Big
Bang Theory but I was into all the other
ones and I took my favorite has to be
the Bob Newhart the I love the mash one
I have that on VHS and I wore the tape
out watching it oh wow yeah and I just
showed my age with that